[Music]
malcolm in the middle star frankie munez
grew up in front of audiences
from his hit show to his starring roles
in agent cody banks and big fat liar
he's kept a low profile
sense so here's what munez has been up
to since saying goodbye
to playing malcolm after the final
episode of malcolm in the middle aired
in 2006
fans were eager to find out what muniz
would do next but he needed a change of
pace
even before going to hollywood muniz was
active in theater which was how he
eventually transitioned into appearing
in commercials and landing his first
film roles
muniz had been playing malcolm for six
years and he was ready for some time
away from the camera
muniz once said that by the time his run
as malcolm was over he had quote
done little else but work for 12 years
that kind of schedule
would be difficult enough for an adult
actor to handle let alone a child actor
he didn't leave hollywood all together
but significantly cut back on his
schedule
mostly making one-off appearances on tv
shows or movies
after shooting agent cody banks 2 in
2004
muniz began to think about landing more
mature roles
but he admitted that dealing with the
transition was challenging
in an interview with about the actor
commented that he assumed that upon
becoming a legal adult
he'd begin getting more mature roles but
that wasn't the case
saying i haven't been scared but i've
really been thinking about it a lot
that i really have to do something at
this point right now to break the mold
i really need to do something different
but muniz struggled to navigate this
phase in his career
after becoming so well known for his
past characters that he wasn't taken
seriously in other roles for instance in
2007
he switched gears with a role in the
rom-com
my sexiest year which received middling
reviews
and in 2008 he appeared in extreme movie
which was panned by critics
eventually muniz decided to take up a
new passion that surprised some of his
fans
in 2001 he drove the pace car in the
toyota 500 and in 2004
he won the toyota pro celebrity race
however he knew that there was no way
he'd be able to balance both
acting and racing in 2006 he decided to
simply go on hiatus from acting for a
while
telling bbc news i want to want to act
and right now i want to race you can't
really juggle both
because if you do you just don't get
enough time in the car
this wasn't an impulsive decision on
muniz's part
he spent plenty of time training to get
behind the wheel
and he impressed his instructors he
competed with jensen motorsport
and his solid performance in pre-season
testing earned
praise from team boss eric jensen muniz
raced for several years
closing out his racing career with
another showing at the toyota pro
celebrity race in 2011.
while racing muniz got into an accident
and became
seriously injured saying on dancing with
the stars
i had a crash and broke my back and
injured my hands and ribs
it took him quite a while to recover and
he still feels the effects of these
injuries today
he admitted that he and his dance
partner whitney carson
ended up talking about his injuries all
the time during rehearsals because he
felt like he had
quote the creaky old body of a 71 year
old he didn't let his past injuries hold
him back from pursuing
other exciting opportunities and he
still considers himself an active
athletic person at the age of seven
muniz got his first concussion
while playing soccer and since then he
has suffered eight more
later in life he began dealing with
frightening mini strokes
in fact munich says that he had visited
the emergency room
on at least 15 different occasions
because of these
adverse health events the fact that he
survived his first
mini stroke was nothing if not
miraculous
he realized that something was wrong
while he was riding his motorcycle
and while losing his vision he somehow
made it home to his family
i kind of lost all peripheral vision and
like started feeling like i was losing
my balance and uh
just started feeling really really
uncomfortable to this day
muniz has no clear answers as to why he
has suffered from many strokes
he's always been very focused on living
a healthy lifestyle
telling entertainment weekly i'm 31 i've
never sipped alcohol
i've never touched a drug or taken a
drag of a cigarette
the only thing i felt was stress i'm a
high strung person i just like to always
be moving
i'm not good at relaxing for the most
part munis hasn't endured long-term
complications from experiencing mini
strokes but he has dealt with one
setback
memory loss muniz admits that today he
doesn't remember
much of his time working on malcolm in
the middle but munis says that for the
most part his memory loss doesn't bother
him
although dealing with these health
issues can be difficult he chooses to
stay focused on the positives
his wife paige price even helps them
keep track of things they've done
together by writing them down in a
journal
as muniz told people i only know what
it's like to be me
and if i don't let it bother me i just
try to live the most fulfilling best
life i can
i really try to take advantage of my
time and i've got a lot in my life
muniz has a wide variety of interests in
addition to acting
and racing he's also passionate about
music he began playing the drums when he
was 12
and he always enjoyed it as a hobby and
a momentary reprieve from the spotlight
i'm the drummer you know like no one
looks at the drummer you know what i
mean you look at the front man
sorry man no but nobody weren't nobody
looks at the drummer
in 2012 muniz decided to put his racing
career on hold
in order to pursue music professionally
he joined the band you hang up as a
drummer when they were unsigned
it all started with a random message
from aaron brown
the band's lead vocalist and guitarist
as muniz told pin live
aaron called and asked if i'd be
interested in jamming with him
since he knew i played drums i was like
i don't want to jam with you guys
i want to be in the band later muniz
went on to play drums with the band
kingsfoil and in 2017 he switched gears
and began
managing the band astro lasso taking
them on tour with we the kings
although munez has taken long stretches
of time away from acting
he never walked away from the industry
throughout the years
since malcolm in the middle ended muniz
has occasionally done
guest spots on tv shows and appeared in
supporting roles in movies
unfortunately for munez most of his
films have not gotten glowing reviews in
2016
he appeared in the family flick another
day in paradise
which told the story of two girls
helping their widowed father
accept their mother's death in 2018
muniz went in a new direction when he
starred in the horror film the black
string
interestingly enough critics weren't
crazy about the film
but muniz's performance did earn some
praise
with critic britney witherspoon writing
elevating this script from a derivative
and simple one is no easy task
but muniz does it effortlessly muniz
moved to arizona because he was ready to
get away from los angeles
telling penn live i always say moving
out of la
and moving to phoenix i feel saved my
life
later muniz settled down in scottsdale
with his partner
paige price whom he married in 2019 the
couple
loved the area's unique charm and old
west vibes
however he says that new developments in
the city have made him a bit concerned
for scottsdale's future
lamenting in an interview with azcentral
it's becoming like a little bit of a
mini la
not that i want to get into an la bash
fest but i moved here because i love
what it has here
i hope it doesn't grow too big where you
lose some of that charm
muniz and price bought outrageous olive
oils and vinegars in scottsdale arizona
and became
small business owners my fiancee and i
were looking to do something together
and we found this little the store in
this brand and we loved it
and we took it over and muniz didn't
simply hire people to run the store for
him
he took a very hands-on approach with a
couple bottling
labeling and sealing everything
themselves as he explained
in an interview with azcentral it's a
lot of work
but it's really rewarding when people
come in and rave about the product
muniz and price were genuinely proud of
the olive oils and other products they
put on the shelves
before selling the shop in 2020 in
september 2020
muniz and price excitedly announced that
they were going to become parents
the couple revealed to their fans that
they would be welcoming a baby boy into
their family
in the announcement muniz said while we
still believe
it's the little moments in between the
big ones that make you feel happiest
nothing quite compares to hearing your
little one's heartbeat
from that moment munis's focus in life
completely shifted
he immediately started suggesting baby
names and wondering what their child's
future would be like
the couple welcomed their son maz on
march
22nd 2021 and now it looks like muniz
will be focused on spending lots of time
with his family
and enjoying fatherhood fans of muniz
will be happy to hear that despite
stepping away from hollywood
he has no intentions of retiring from
acting altogether
early in 2021 muniz had a guest role as
corey harris on the comedic crime drama
the rookie
he's also set to play a deputy in the
western film
hot bath and a stiff drink too and has a
role in
road to capri a comedy film about two
brothers who only discover that they're
related after their father's death
while muniz might never commit as much
time to acting as he once did
he'll likely stick around in hollywood
for years to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite child stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you